hey i'm jason marsden I directed the
author part of Locker 13 Locker 13 calm
and with reason a fellow filmmaker here
I'm an Atlanta now writer director of
Canary suicides website website no
website no one so gentlemen what was the
reason for starting these projects but
in what inspired you
I know creativity in me if you're in
this business you want to direct you
wanna make a film the opportunity arises
and you get a good story and uh there
you go you take advantage anybody hey
what are you I was really frustrated
doing movies cuz movies have to you know
take a lot of money to do so we went to
do a really small film with no actor
something that we can shoot in one day
and can I interrupt for a second so most
people who want to get started they want
to do shorts but this dude did features
in jump too short speeches how do you
know huh you just said that yes so every
part of your team so money bucket of
features for you I did two really cheap
features
two big budget sharks are you getting
the word out now there's about I am
submitting to fair and various film
festivals like Holly shorts
I'm trying festivals as well so Facebook
is definitely getting you know a lotta
notoriety now in sweaters and I gotta
get more socially like for it to the
social networks that I used to